CBS News legal analyst Ricky Kleman was
a prosecutor and defense attorney she
has covered every Simpson case Ricky
good morning my name what happens now
when he gets out where can he live what
can he do they are working on the
interstate compact so that he can be
transferred for his parole from Nevada
to Florida he has lived in Florida
before he has substantial ties to the
community and so everyone would expect
that with a good plan for his future in
parole that he will in fact be
transferred however there are conditions
of parole there standard ones in Nevada
there'll be others in Florida and one of
these conditions that he has to think
about is not the simple one about no
alcohol use or drug use I'm sure that
after nine years in prison that is not a
consideration but we do have to think
about the fact that he has to comply
with all laws now that means big ones to
little ones we also have to think about
the fact about his right of association
no convicted felons no people in trouble
or criminal activity but also who they
even the slightest violation could put
him back in jail yes it could what you
do is you've got to really look that
there's another grid we looked at the
grid in terms of his possibility of
parole there's another grid about what a
violation does and what ultimately would
happen if he runs a stop sign do I
expect him to be violated and put back
in prison no I don't however if he were
recklessly driving ran a stop sign and
hurt or killed someone that's a very
different matter
remember this his life has changed does
it matter that he lied before the parole
board saying that he'd led a conflict
conflict free life I don't think that
the parole board looked at Oh Jay
Simpsons exaggeration or what some might
say is a delusional statement as
something that would they would call a
lie and it would have disqualified him
in his mind he certainly thinks he led a
conflict-free life in on any objective
criteria he of course was involved with
conflict for many years not only back to
the times of domestic violence but even
with an altercation in traffic
can floor enough during a previous
parole here and he had promised to take
a number of courses I don't think he
completed any of them except for the
alternatives to violence which he kept
touting can you tell us a little bit
about that that course the alternative
to violence course he said should be
mandated for every prisoner he believes
that it is life changing and he believes
that he learned a lot from it and that
he is a changed person the future
remains to be seen if that is a true
statement
that is correct Ricky clima thank you
very much in our next half hour we will
talk to Ron Goldman's father and sister
Fred and Kim Goldman in their first
interview since this parole hearing that
is ahead only on CBS this morning